a perfect beard is irresistible to all
people you get a better job when you got
a nice beard
you get better people you get better
friends my kids
are now studying for the s.a.t and
they're only four years old because my
beer is going to be tight after this
what's going on guys it's your man v
marcus harvey the barber star here at
the musa layer
grooming art gallery and we are here to
show you how to get your beard back to
its original youthful look
by coloring it if you want to have that
little extra freshness you want to you
know
take a couple years off you you color it
a little bit just a tad bit just a tad
bit guys
so your lady don't even know that you
that young in that fly you know what i'm
[Music]
saying
you have to pick the right color you
don't want to go too dark to where it
looks like shoe polish
a lot of you brothers know what i'm
talking about y'all know what i'm
talking about there's been a lot of
people out there who might put a
too dark color so you want to get the
color that matches your undertone of
your skin
so mine is more of a darker brown and
that's what i'm going to use today for
you guys
let's go ahead and do the color step
one preparing your beard
i like to always get my beard ready so
that it can have a clean surface so what
do i do
i like to get bevel face wash wash my
face prior to me doing any type of
service on myself whether it be lining
my beard up whether it be
giving myself a nice close shave you
want to always have a very very clean
surface
now that our beard is clean we're going
to continue to
pick it out and as you can see it's a
lot easier to pick through your beard
when it's clean detangled you can use a
lot of beard wash
also be kind to your beard your beard
loves you
your beard your wing man you might as
well treat them right right
step two draw your line
we're gonna get you guys right in focus
so we have one more hack
[Music]
your girl probably has this barber
pencil is what we call it you can get
those online
and this helps you measure your beard it
allows you to make the line first before
you cut
now a lot of times we want to go in
there and thinking that we professionals
and you want to go straight in cut and
now your beard all short and short down
and
now your barber has to build your beard
back up but for us to kind of keep you
honest measure twice cut once so that's
why we're going to use this stencil
you're going to be able to see
where you're making your mistakes where
your line is going to go and that way
it's going to be a guide
so that you can have a perfect beautiful
beard
like mine so i'm going to start my line
from the top
and i'm going to work all the way to the
end of my mustache just this region
right here
i'm also going to blow up bubbles the
bubble stretches the skin more so that
you can get a more accurate line
a more accurate depiction of where i'm
going to put my clipper
now that i've completed this side i'm
going to continue
the line by starting from the mustache
and working my way up
so i have a completely straight line on
both sides
i have twins and not cousins y'all know
what i'm talking about
and i'm doing the same on the outside
stretching my neck out also does the
exact same thing as blowing a bubble on
my beard
because you have natural curves in your
face natural dips in your face
you kind of want to give a flat surface
so that you can make sure
that that line continuously is straight
next we're going to line up the beard
i'm going to be using the bevel trimmer
i love it because it's actually cordless
you can move the blade
up and down to your comfort
let's begin i'm going to follow the line
from
my mustache all the way out i'm going to
blow a bubble
and with this being a core of this
clipper i can also have this upside down
so that i can have
a clear point of view of what i'm doing
with my beard
[Music]
now we're going to get to the mustache
because right now i got that scotty from
the whispers mustache
join in that's that love train mustache
join the love train
[Applause]
[Music]
now that we have this outlined and lined
up
it's time for us to move to step three
the pairing of the color
before we get started we always want to
do a patch test what is a patch test
it's actually
to see if you're allergic to the color
so what you have to do you just get a
little piece of that color
and you just put it behind your ear if
it itches
wash it off immediately that might not
be the product for you
if it has ammonium or ppd those are the
things that might cause you to have a
breakout
but if it doesn't react it's on
real quick professional hack you get a
standard brush with your kit what most
professionals like to do
is we like to cut that bottom row of
the brush off while you ask it allows me
to have a little bit more control over
where i go you're able to maneuver the
color a little bit better
and be a little bit more precise of
course this color will stain your
clothes
i typically wear black underneath the
cape that i'm going to wear also just in
case anything
seeps through the cape or you
accidentally touch something and it gets
on your shirt
as you're doing your color you make sure
that if you any type of splat or
anything you can easily remove it before
it stains
right after it hits your skin go ahead
and wipe it off before it absorbs
make sure that you have a nice complete
look only on your beard and not all over
your face
[Music]
all right guys now i'm going to show you
two ways now some of you guys say hey i
want
the whole fountain of youth i want to
look like when i was 22
and i was doing left hand layups
slapping the backboard dunking on folks
or some of you guys want to just keep
some of that gray in
so you look like you could pay a couple
bills you want to keep some of that
great so i'm gonna do both
i have my little gray patch right here
that i'm going to leave open
and then i'm going to also cover this
one all the way up so that you can see
the difference between the two
establishing our top line
here we go again i'm blowing out that
bubble
i like to do a technique called press
and drag i
press and drag the color down so that
it's an even
distribution of the color and it doesn't
have overwhelming spots
if you are really nervous and you still
want to make sure that you don't create
any stains you can get
some priming oil or you can get some
vaseline or oil sheen and spray right on
top
of where you do not want to be colored
and that way
the color does not set you can go over
the same spot twice just to make sure
that it's straight
all right now that i've established
that top line you can see it's
developing the colors developing now
i'm going to leave this patch out here
guys right now to be
natural i still want to look like a dope
dad
so i'm going to keep that in there i
have a secondary brush
also that i use after
i put the color in just so that i can
spread it evenly through the beard
all right now i use a larger brush you
can have these at any of your local
beauty supply stores you can find
this brush right at the front counter
now i'm just gently massaging it into
my beard to make sure that i catch all
the gray hairs that i wanted to catch
you do not need to let it sit in long
you will need to watch
what the instructions say on the box and
that's as long as you need to let it
develop this one specifically said five
minutes
for those who want to leave some gray
hair you want to leave a little bit more
maturity a little
bit more wisdom in your beard there's a
trick a hack that we have where you get
vaseline
or any petroleum jelly and you put it
right on where you want to keep the
grate that way
the color cannot penetrate so where i
left my gray patch is right here i like
this little strip right here
you can still see that it's gray out
here but i've colored the rest of my
beard
so our next step very simple
go watch out let's go
step four set and rinse
once the time that is allocated for the
beard to process
you rinse it out twice you do two
shampoos and a conditioner
you want to be able to make sure that
you do this last process the correct way
the best way to do it is by having a
black towel to make sure that you don't
get
any stains on any light colored towels
shampoo once
lather it up really really nice rinse it
out
shampoo again lather it up use cold
water
why use cold water because cold closes
the cuticle
cold closes the cuticle and locks in the
color and that's what you want to do for
longevity for your beard
to stay youthful add conditioner
lather it in rinse it once again and
that way you lock in all that moisture
that your beard is going to be needing
after this color process
step 5 lock in the color and final
touches
you don't want to just color your beard
you want to add that moisture you want
to give that richness to it so what do
you do
get that bevel beard oil
is one of the products that i like to
use as well as
its beard balm
and all you're going to do is just get a
dime size
put it on the back of your finger
multiply it work it through your beard
oh my gosh that's rich oh
that's rich look at that look at that
shine look at that luster
after you've got done doing all those
processes to your beard you want to
continue to
pour as much moisture into your beard as
possible now of course i also used
an extrinsic toner to get underneath my
neck and all the areas that i cut before
make sure that i don't get any
irritation or any razor bumps we all
know
ain't none worse than some razorbunch as
you guys could see
the vaseline trick that we did to lead
graze in
worked we still have these grays where
all the other grays in my beard
are no longer it left me some maturity
right there
now let's just touch the beard one more
time we can make sure that we have
a very very refined line
i think we're in there guys how do you
guys feel you feel good you feel young
you feel youthful yes you of course you
do because you were here with
me go give your wife a hug she already
looking at you teddy i see it all right
brenda i see you better watch it
all right guys we did it we made it we
look super young
super fresh i am your guy your teacher
the marcus harvey the barber star
thank you for coming to the musa layer
in atlanta georgia
gq we keep you fly man check us out next
time